foreign
simple just to power your business with
100 renewable energy but the detail that
goes in and the industry expertise
that's required to really understand not
just how much energy you're consuming
across different parts of your business
but also what's the best most cost
effective way to drive new wind and
solar to the grids around the world it's
complicated and not everybody has the
opportunity to build an internal team of
energy experts and it really comes back
to the opportunity to partner
[Music]
foreign
take a step back and think about Amazon
as a company it's a complicated place we
operate data centers distribution
centers warehouses commercial offices
grocery stores and all these different
types of operations have a different set
of challenges that we're trying to
tackle we set this goal to get to 100
renewable energy by 2030. we started off
with questions like hey how much energy
did we use in India last year or last
month or yesterday understanding our
usage across time and across geographies
and then mapping that against where are
the available solar and wind projects
that we could possibly invest in and
figure out where can we be a catalyst to
really Drive New clean energy to the
grids where we operate we realize very
quickly that we cannot go at this alone
we needed to Galvanize Collective action
across the entire economy and that's how
we launched the climate pledge which is
really just that it's a pledge and a
commitment to get the net zero in
alignment with climate science but an
invitation to partner and their
Collective call to action for other
companies to take part in this journey
with us so when we set out our second
headquarters location in Arlington
Virginia we tried to think about how are
we going to power this new campus with
100 renewable energy
we got to know Arlington County and
realized they also had a commitment to
power their government buildings as well
as the entire Community with 100
renewable energy is over time so that
instant partnership allowed us to come
together and say what are some cool
options that we can explore together to
bring new renewable energy to to
Arlington we took a step back to
evaluate how much power will this campus
consume how much power will our local
Whole Foods stores our distribution
center stores consume we're able to add
that all up and then talk to the county
to ask them the exact same questions how
much power do you need to achieve your
clean energy goals so we combine those
numbers and really came to Dominion the
local utility provider with the need of
basically 120 megawatt solar farm would
meet all of our needs we were able to
strike an agreement that would allow us
to bring that 120 megawatt solar farm
online that would eventually feed the
grids that feed government buildings
Amazon stores as well as our new campus
in Arlington
when we start our journey we were at 42
renewable energy in 2019 and fast
forward to today we're powered by 85
renewable energy across the world
we have a chance to really accelerate
that commitment to get to 100 renewable
energy from 2030 down to 2025. we have
more work to do uh but I think the the
proof points we have with renewable
energy gave us a blueprint on how we can
attack other parts of the climate crisis
yet to be solved how do we decarbonize
Concrete in our buildings how we think
about Aviation from a zero carbon
perspective how do we know what our
buildings consume how do we know where
we need to get to to hit our goals
Amazon wants to get the Net Zero because
we don't have an option the climate
science is clear we need Partnerships to
drive change at scale that's really
going to drive carbon out of our global
economy and that was really the spirit
of the climate pledge and a call to
action to solve the climate crisis